so we are here with a story that
introduces and ends the character of
Abraxas so Abraxas is one of the most
powerful beings ever in the history of
Marvel Comics and in this video we're
gonna find out why so what this does
here is this initially picks up with a
handful of characters you've got a
character by the name of Marvel girl
Valeria Richards we'll talk about her
here in a minute because anybody who
knows anything about Marvel Comics in
this point in time is just kind of like
oh God then we also have Frankie Ray she
is a Herald of Galactus but this one's
different then you've got the other
members of the Fantastic Four along with
Franklin Richards who will be incredibly
important towards the end of this story
but what's going on here is Reed is
tracking what he refers to as an anomaly
which is an effect the head of Galactus
from an alternate reality now we know
this because Nova chimes in and Nova
even says she's from a different
universe that what had happened is that
following the death of Galactus in the
main Marvel universe that Abraxas
basically just started showing up and
killing all these different versions of
Galactus now we'll learn more about the
the relationship between abraxis and
Galactus in this video but in effect
when Abraxas had killed her version of
Galactus she had ended up here in the
main Marvel Universe it wasn't
explicitly explained why although we
will find out and in effect she's the
one that informs the Fantastic Four of
the nature of Abraxas and the danger
that he poses now for Franklin Richards
he talks about how he sees Abraxas in
his dreams but he only ever really knows
him as the dark man now what it does
here is it switches over to the Silver
Surfer who's basically arriving
alongside the new Captain Marvel as well
as like moon dragon the daughter of
draxa Destroyer also known as Heather
Douglas Quasar Wendell Vaughn and what
Reid does is he kind of explains what's
been going on behind the scenes and what
he does here is he says that like this
head of Galactus has basically been
transported to where the Fantastic Four
are at or at least where everybody's
meeting and what he does here is he
explains the head of Galactus has been
transported here to the blue area of the
Moon the oxygen-rich area of the moon
and the reason why the head is here is
because of the fact that once all these
weird things started happening you
suddenly started having other characters
from different realities popping up in
the main Marvel Universe of course Reed
had also gone to visit uwachu the
Watcher hoping he would have some kind
of guidance on what was going on but to
watch The Watcher had basically gone
insane he didn't know who he was and
then fell into a catatonic state so
whatever it is that's happening here
with regards to abraxis is basically
something astronomical that people just
can't necessarily fathom and so
following that Reed Richards traveled to
an alternate reality to meet with a guy
named Dr Druid who's probably one of the
least important characters you're ever
going to hear about in your entire life
but what was revealed to them in meeting
with eternity is that what Frankie Ray
had explained was accurate that abraxis
is a being who has basically been
Unleashed based on the Multiverse and is
traveling across every single Universe
killing every version of Galactus he can
find but is also on the hunt for
something called the ultimate nullifier
now the ultimate nullifier is one of the
most powerful artifacts and arguably the
most powerful artifact in the entirety
of Marvel Comics it's Beyond The
Infinity Gauntlet Cosmic cubes the whole
nine yards the idea behind the ultimate
nullifier is that if a person has enough
fortitude when they point the ultimate
nullifier at an object when they pull
the trigger it'll basically wipe that
object from existence not only will it
be wiped from existence it'll be like it
never existed and what if raxis is
trying to do is literally Wipe Out the
entirety of the Multiverse using the
ultimate nullifier and if he's able to
get his hands on it he can do it because
he's a multiversal cosmic entity that
basically just represents absolute
destruction and so what ends up
happening is that in the midst of this
when all these different uh really like
bogeys if you want to call them that
right these anomalies are heading
towards the blue area of the Moon that
you end up having the Fantastic Four who
scramble and respond along with
everybody else now there's kind of a
Mist right that's like permeating this
Blue Area only for Silver Surfer to be
caught in it and to be annihilated right
he's literally destroyed disintegrated
completely wiped out when it comes to
these like monstrous forces the
Fantastic Four can only do so much they
are immensely powerful and that's when
one of these guys references Johnny
Storm as the person they need to go
after the person they need to attack now
for the most part the Fantastic Four are
able to hold their own they ultimately
end up defeating these forces and it's
really more by way of like Captain
Marvel and uh Wendell Von and Quasar
that they even pull it off in the first
place but then a kind of uh Apparition
of like Abraxas appears and kind of
taunts them for a minute and then
basically disappears but what ends up
happening is Heather Douglas picks up on
the fact that one of these guys
basically said that like Johnny Storm's
a person we have to go after when that
happened she scanned his mind and what
she realized is that the Watcher had
taken the location of the ultimate
nullifier and placed it somewhere in the
Multiverse and then he took the location
of the ultimate nullifier and put it in
the mind of Johnny Storm so it could
only be accessed by Johnny Storm nobody
knows where the ultimate nullifier is in
one of these three locations they don't
even know if it's split into three
pieces and each of these three pieces
are put into these three locations but
what ends up happening in response to
that is a fantastic four do the only
thing they can do which is jump into the
Multiverse and try to find these
different shards or pieces of the
ultimate nullifier now of course what's
kind of Bonkers about this is that when
it comes to Abraxas he's everywhere and
nowhere at the same time a perfect
example of this is he basically
manifests as a physical statue that
basically gets up turns into his
physical form and then just kind of
looks over the moon and sort of Muses to
himself right Vinnie Vini Vici so it's
one of those cool elements where like
this guy is everywhere in nowhere at the
same time he's like the agents from The
Matrix but while you have these
different alternate realities that are
almost kind of converging into the main
Marvel universe itself so you kind of
have like the Avengers and the X-Men
sort of responding where they can when
they can the meat and potatoes of this
is that in the midst of all of this
Marvel girl Valeria ends up realizing
that abraxis is coming to her location
and what she does is something called
time dancing where she can basically
jump through the time stream or from one
reality to the next and basically flees
now the reason why she does this even
with abraxis following her where he
jumps to a location that she can't get
to is because Valeria Richards at least
this version of her character is not
native to this universe so see if you
can wrap your head around this crazy
Malarkey so the whole basis behind this
story is tell retcon Valeria Richards
that's the whole basis behind it that's
it it's to wreck on our character and
give her a cohesive origin the way this
played out in Marvel Comics as insane as
this sounds is that Valeria was supposed
to be the second child of Reed and Susan
what ended up happening is that Franklin
Richards due to the either difficulty of
the birth or him being jealous of her
having a second kid it's not overly
explained and in some ways it really
depends on what Marvel fan you're
talking to he effectively whisked her
away to an alternate reality and she was
raised by that reality's version of
Susan storm and Doctor Doom why because
that version of Doctor Doom was a good
guy Reed Richards had died in that
alternate reality and Valeria was just
raised by them to become a hero she
ultimately ended up time dancing ended
up in the main Marvel Universe and has
effectively been here for quite some
time but of course the retcon right the
change to her character's history that
Marvel's going to give us will actually
come later in this story and we'll talk
about that you know once we cross that
bridge but for Johnny Storm and Frankie
Ray the two of them partnering up is
because Frankie Ray and the main Marvel
Universe was at one point a love
interest of Johnny Storm and while these
two are not love interests because
they're from two different realities
they know enough about each other's
Powers their strengths and weaknesses to
work together but there's actually
another caveat behind this which is kind
of cool now for the other members of the
Fantastic Four Susan storm for example
she's sent into an alternate reality
where in that Universe she became a
doctor but like they don't really do
anything meaningful or important right
it's just one of these things where it's
like imagine what she would look like in
a different Universe right there's one
reality where she married name or the
Submariner as an example or something
along those lines but the important
thing here kind of again focusing on the
main brunt behind this Franklin Richards
was actually whisked away and sent to
Roma in order to basically keep him safe
or at least to allow him some measure to
recoup and to effectively figure out a
way to win along with Valeria who
effectively time danced their Now who is
the character of roma roma is actually
one of the coolest characters in Marvel
Comics and she's not overly powerful she
is but she's not but she's really really
interesting so a lot of you guys already
know about the Multiverse right like a
infinite number of universes all
coexisting at the same time what you
have here is something called other
world and you even have like the Citadel
of Merlin Merlin is basically like the
same relent of Arthurian Legend his
daughter is Roma Marlin's long since
been dead but she's kind of like the
multiversal guardian she keeps an eye on
things she hasn't really been seen or
heard from in Marvel Comics for quite
some time because she was killed
although there's no reason to believe
that she can't simply just return but
something to understand is the
relationship between her and Franklin is
very close and all of that really comes
out of the end of the onslaught Saga in
the 1990s which is to say basically the
deaths of all the superheroes except for
like the Fantastic Four the X-Men and
Spider-Man and Franklin rich shirts
resurrecting them all from the dead and
putting them in an alternate reality
called Heroes Reborn so it was kind of
cool it was technically the second
version of counter Earth and Marvel
Comics but the important thing here is
that them being under the protection of
Roma almost kind of places them outside
of the Multiverse so the expectation is
that if abraxis is the living embodiment
of just destruction on a multiversal
level he shouldn't necessarily be able
to access them but her concern here is
that if Franklin and Valeria and those
guys are not able to find a way to
defeat Abraxas he will get the ultimate
nullifier and it will lead to the
destruction of everything and so what
she does is in addition to Franklin and
Valeria she brings in saturnin now why
saturnin's here I'm not entirely sure
maybe she's just here for the heck of it
saturnin is the head of What's called
the omniversal development Court her job
is to basically monitor every Universe
across the Multiverse and make sure that
like the Avengers come into existence
around the same time the X-Men come into
existence so on and so forth sometimes
that happens like you're supposed to
sometimes it doesn't because of guys
like mad Jim Jaspers but she seems to be
here as more of just like why not throw
her in right it's just one of those
interesting elements but their job here
is to really kind of monitor watch how
things unfold and then only at the
proper time will Franklin Richards
intervene now a lot of you guys are
probably asking yourself if Franklin's
so powerful that he can like alter
reality on a universal scale and his
ability to do this is presumably
Universal across any and all universes
right you throw them in an alternate
reality and he can alter the very fabric
of the universe itself in that alternate
reality why not just send him in and a
lot of this is because Roma is one of
those very Cloak and Dagger characters
she's one of those characters Marvel
brings in when like they want to tell a
story but they don't want to take like
the easy way out so it's like Roma has a
plan and we just have to wait until the
plan manifests to see what happens and
that's basically it
not the best explanation there ever was
but Marvel is very hand wavy when it
comes to the plans of Roma and how those
things unfold and so what you end up
doing here is you pick up with What's
called the crossroad of all reality
which is to say essentially a Nexus and
that what goes on here is the location
of the ultimate nullifier is discovered
and Johnny Storm of course gets his
hands on it and then in turn is like
okay let's grab this thing and get out
of here only for Frankie Ray to turn on
him and what had actually happened is
that yes abraxis had shown up to Nova's
reality and kill that version of
Galactus but instead of Frankie Ray just
like fleeing that universe and showing
up in the main Marvel Universe and
asking for Aid she actually became a
Herald of Abraxas she was effectively
his spy operating within the main Marvel
Universe and that what she'd been doing
here was just biting her time waiting
for the moment when the ultimate
nullifier is found and then capture it
and hand it over to Abraxas and that's
exactly what happens that in fact when
this takes place that Nova shows up to
the realm of Roma and then in turn that
gives Abraxas a Gateway right she
basically becomes a beacon and it's like
over there and like he just goes running
over to that location and then kills
Roma on the spot like just annihilates
her and then in turn goes to seize the
ultimate nullifier for himself now the
kicker to this is that before he can
take possession of it Reid Richards is
able to pick up on the fact that Johnny
Storm has the nullifier and then whisks
everybody back to the main Marvel
Universe the problem is that even when
they're brought back to Earth itself
Frankie Ray is still standing like right
there like right next to Abraxas and so
abraxis just takes the nullifier from
her but you get this really cool moment
of what he says like now with the
ultimate nullifier in my grasp there
isn't a soul in the combined universes
who can stop me not a single one and
Franklin Richards is listening to that
whole conversation unfold not only that
what seems to have been happening here
is that as Abraxas was going through and
killing these different iterations of
Galactus not only that Frankie Ray
herself basically creates what are
called her kind of angels right like
essentially duplicates of herself now
what's really cool here and it's one of
these things where you can kind of go
either way depending on how you're
approaching it you could take the
argument that these different versions
of Nova or basically just Frankie Ray
duplicating herself given her ability to
manipulate the power Cosmic along with
what are likely some adjustments from
abraxis in terms of her powers being
modified you could also look at it from
the perspective that like they were all
different Heralds of Galactus from
across the Multiverse we're not really
given a definitive answer all we're told
here is Nova my trusted Herald be a lamb
take your angels and destroy the
Fantastic Four and she simply says love
to so it really seems to be the first
where she just basically duplicated
herself but as for why she even betrayed
or really sided with a branches in the
first place this is rooted in the fact
that what she says is that in her
reality Galactus showed up to Earth in
order to consume it much in the same way
he showed up to Zin law and noren rad
offered himself to become the Silver
Surfer the difference here is that
Frankie Ray was quote unquote chosen
although really more offered by that
reality's version of Reed to become the
herald of Galactus in order to spare
Earth but even when that was done he
destroyed Earth anyway so with that kind
of anger and Vengeance really operating
as her very inner being that in turn led
her to basically join Abraxas now one of
the funny things about this is that even
despite the efforts of everybody
involved which even includes these other
characters from alternate realities who
realize the danger of abraxis and just
kind of jumping into The Fray and trying
to help defeat the different versions of
Nova none of them can stand against
Abraxas none of them can actually defeat
this guy and so at the end of the day it
really all comes down to the hour of
Franklin Richards because what ends up
happening here is that Franklin he tells
his mom I have to be brave I have to do
good like mom and dad taught me I have
to make it so everything is all right
grab my hand Valerie and then in turn
using the three of them that's where you
get the retcon right that's where you
get the great big huge change that what
ends up happening here is that Valeria
herself is basically quote unquote
destroyed and in turn she well it
doesn't come into a later comic but
she's deposited in the womb of Susan
storm in order to be reborn so the way
her character's history works right and
this is like Valeria Richards as you see
her now in 2023 at the time we're making
this video in Marvel Comics the way this
history works is that she was basically
the second child of Reed and Susan in
the main Marvel Universe She was whisked
away to an alternate reality by Franklin
Richards raised to become Marvel girl in
that alternate reality she showed up in
the main Marvel Universe and then based
on this story she is is sent back into
the womb of Susan storm so she can be
reborn in this universe as the actual
second child of Reed and Susan is it
necessary absolutely not it's the most
ridiculous red con ever in the history
of Marvel Comics and it's just overly
complex and kind of stupid but
nonetheless it would have been a lot
easier for a character to just die and
then like Susan gets knocked up by Reed
again and she's like let's just name
this child Valeria after like that
alternate reality version of our
daughter that we met and just call it a
day but I thought that was worth
mentioning the kicker here though is
that with Franklin's powers and given
what he's capable of remember Franklin
can alter reality on a universal scale
what he does is he kind of quote unquote
wishes on a star which is kind of a
weird little moment here now what ends
up happening here is really kind of
wonky and is kind of hand wavy but is
also a testament to the level of power
that Franklin Richards has that the way
in which he uses his powers is that he
literally sees a star in the sky and so
follow following this what you get is
Franklin Richards using his powers and
probably one of the most popular ways
that people talk about whenever they
talk about Franklin that Valeria is
still here because this alternate
reality of Valeria is intact I mean if
you really want to look at it at a weird
way Franklin basically made sure that
his mom got knocked up and will
essentially give birth to like a second
child it's one of those weird things but
with this alternate reality version of
Valeria there alongside Franklin what
they end up doing is combining their
powers Franklin quote unquote wishes on
a star quite literally he sees a star in
the sky
and then he wishes for things to
essentially go back to normal and
effectively eternity and infinity
manifest and then Galactus is reborn and
resurrected from the dead like he simply
just appears I am that I am now the
funny thing here is that abraxis takes
no concern and doesn't even care and
it's just kind of like it doesn't matter
to me right I have the ultimate
nullifier but one of the things to
remember is that back in the original
Galactus trilogy in Marvel Comics it was
established that the nullifier was
created by Galactus so he controls it as
much as anybody else possibly could and
really more so than anybody could and
then once Frankie Ray attacks Galactus
he pulls the ultimate nullifier from
Abraxas directly and then when Frankie
Ray launches an attack against Galactus
at the behest of Abraxas the ultimate
nullifier simply falls out of his hands
and Reed Richards picks it up and when
he does he fires the null of fire at
Abraxas and then all of reality kind of
shatters disappears and then
restructures itself this is like a
massive retcon like reality basically
blinked out for a second and came back
and when it did everybody who was
basically dead before ended up returning
which includes the Silver Surfer
Galactus is back to his normal self
Valeria Richards from the alternate
reality is gone and Susan storm is
pregnant with what's going to be the
Valeria Richards that you guys are all
aware of in Marvel Comics again the the
whole reason the story was written was
to retcon the character of Valeria but
it is cool to see Abraxas with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and I'll catch you all later
peace